hallo leute die dabei waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge laufen
und laufen heute live von der gamescom
2022 haller kolumna ist mal wieder
unterwegs und wird für euch das beste
food die besten drinks und die coolsten
spiele
für unsere erste speise heute werden wir
etwas ganz feines ausprobieren dafür
müssen wir nicht mal einen cent bezahlen
kommt mit zum frische wird uns hier eine
große auswahl an
leckereien präsentiert wir haben brot
mit käse brot mit wurst brot mit salami
noch mal brot mit käse und kuchen ich
als bank experte muss jetzt hier
natürlich mal john wieder gucken so
aussieht und ich muss sagen ist eine
tolle auswahl an blechkuchen wir haben
hier einen russischen zupfkuchen ein
chocolate brownie irgendwas ein
nusskuchen
ist das bachelor- oder kirchen
heidelbeeren aprikose mohnkuchen der
lacht mich tatsächlich am meisten
angehen wenn wir jetzt mal probieren ich
habe letztens erst mit arthur polnisch
gekocht und eigentlich wollte ich einen
mohnkuchen machen weil polen sind
verrückt nach mohnkuchen deswegen wer
sich jetzt auch mohnkuchen schreibt in
die kommentare mit ihrem mohnkuchen
das ist der perfekte start in den tag
der schmeckt wie dieser figur dieser
mohn joghurt und ich habe ich mir noch
gerade ausgesucht und dachte mir so ich
hätte lieber den russischen zu gucken
oder den braun die nehmen sollen die
klassiker aber nein man
das war der kuchen und jetzt stecken wir
die gamescom aus
ich muss aber mental damit neben das
mega und höflich der mohn bekommt von
mir ne glatte zehn von zehn ich habe
hier jetzt jemanden gefunden stellen sie
sich doch einmal bitte vor nein ich bin
frau gamescom
ihnen gehört ihr die gamescom das daran
dass sie gehören ja quasi baugleich
brand ja so ungefähr rmv gamescom möchte
sie in kona tornado mache
hallo verkauft ja auch corona
ok schade
also unsere erste richtige station mein
absoluter lieblingsladen in köln fritten
berg da gibt es einfach die besten
pommes und die allerbesten pommes sind
die pommes putin mit brauner soße und
mozzarella beck das möchte ich so ganz
realistisch hallo ich hätte gerne einmal
die quebec putin
genau sind wahrscheinlich so gottlos
heißt
ja fantastisch und so versucht das immer
zu hause nachzumachen weißt du ich gebe
den natürlich eine glatte zehn von zehn
das sind super fritten damit kann man
nichts falsch machen und bevor timo
anfängt zu weinen gehen wir jetzt rein
und gucken uns mal die spiele an
[Musik]
ich bin da gerade um die ecke gegangen
habe die disney dream leitbilder gesehen
das hat mich ein bisschen magisch
angezogen denn anna von rosen waren dem
spiel zu sehen und dann hat mich so die
eine da angeguckt hat gesagt man muss
zum laufen kommt jetzt gehe ich zur
disney dream will do
war ein aktuelles hoch für eingeladene
person ich habe noch nie so eine harte
tür entdeckt wie bei der xbox xbox area
hat die härtere tür als bergheim
[Musik]
mit diesen vier zoll treppe hochgegangen
und sind jetzt bei asia wok gibt es reis
sandwiches japanischen käsekuchen excuse
meter sind wir wohl dabei also ich
schnapp medien tabletten steht gehen
gibt es natürlich auch das ist ein
reizwort das sieht das ist ein richtig
mit unbedingt anreisen wird vegan
das haben wir hier schicken wie tomate
moment ist ein käsekuchen einen
japanischen käsekuchen ja du solltest
auf jeden fall ein stück probieren und
hier haben wir unsere veganen drei
sandwiches das hat mein herz erobert mit
einer soße das probieren wir jetzt ende
muss auf meinen mund halten
das ist ein kleines reich sandwich
schmeckt nicht mit den hunden büren aber
es erinnert an eine uni die sich sehr
gut die müssen jetzt auch erste sie
möchten wissen wir dieses preislevel
schmeckt schmeckt sehr gut
sehr gesund das gucke darauf dass tomate
darauf lauchzwiebeln der umreißt wir
haben das neue blatt also war eine
geschmacksexplosion alsfeld ein bisschen
auseinander aber es ist eine tolle
alternative wird um etwas kunde sängerin
messe essen wie hannes burger und pizza
das sieht aber überhaupt nicht aus wie
ein schießt kate
der betrag ist ein bisschen kompakt fest
man würde man auch sagen hat wird jetzt
niemals sagen das ist ein käsekuchen ist
er sahneschnitte wir haben jetzt fertig
gegessen und uns ist aufgefallen dass
der preis doch ein bisschen teuer weiß
dafür also acht euro für so ein raise
sandwich und 6 euro für den kuchen wir
haben insgesamt 22 euro für die drei
teile jetzt bezahlt und das hat sich ein
bisschen viel angeführt und dafür war
der geschmack vom kuchen und auch von
den reis sandwiches jetzt nicht so
überragend dass man sagt war auch lass
deine geary bei dir ich will den reis
sandwich
[Musik]
aus live
also wir befinden uns jetzt hier in
halle
5.2 und hier gibt es merchandise also
ist ein shopping herz glücklich und wir
können was kaufen gehen die coupons mal
was es hier so gibt ich bin ehrlich
gesagt schon ziemlich satt und nach
dieser area werden wir mal das saufen in
laufenden saufen auch mal ein bisschen
zelebrieren und paar getränke zu uns
nehmen
es ist vielleicht zeit für uns
geschrieben wir lieben switch emails wir
haben uns zusammen ein waschbär skil
shimano geholt aber ich finde die
designs ein bisschen strangers wissen
dass er sieht aus als bisschen lsd
version von skil-shimano
lsd igel aber sie fühlen sich sehr gut
an dass wir die chance haben special
melo anzufassen versuchte ist hast du
möchtest du denn haben timo möchtest du
das hier haben es wird zeit für einmal
waren de testet von mit simba eine
packung ergibt 40 liter schlamm in dem
man drin baden ich will das irgendwie
kaufen aber es ist auch so eklig es gibt
es auch mit einhorn glitzer bad mit
glitzer schleim timo brauchst du dann
haben wir so neuen kink vielleicht was
findest du hier an die findet hier die
ganz so komische sachen
schneeballschlacht das ganze jahr reicht
für 60 snowboards
dafür dass sich die originalen sinntal
klar
adventskalender ja das nehme ich mir das
ist ja super quote mal sagen ab zum
nächsten standen
[Musik]
ich habe hinter mir gerade die bob ross
mystery box gefunden und sie kostet 50
euro ich bin wirklich an überlegen sie
mitzunehmen und das werde ich jetzt auch
tun ich hole mir eine box die
bob ross mystery box soria war alleine
diese box war es wert diesen 50 euro zu
bezahlen und die packen wir jetzt aus
und saufen ein bisschen denn das
saufenden laufen und laufen steht immer
noch für laufen
[Musik]
vielleicht haben wir ja schon getränk
getrunken wer weiß wir haben uns jetzt
hier in gechillt und ich packe box aus
also ich bin so gespannt was hier drin
ist leute ich bin gespannt wie ein
flitzebogen ich habe bei diesem stand
2009 10 schon mal im mystery boxen
gekauft ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
erinnert da hatte ich aber so eine bts
tüte da waren fantastische sachen drin
ich habe es sehr geliebt deswegen habe
ich die große hoffnung dass diese box
jetzt genauso geil ist ja geplant wenn
ich auf der welt werden und fragte
gleich mit einem mikro in der hand okay
ich weiß nicht was mich erwartet also
ich weiß was ich erwartet habe aber wir
kommen locken entgegen oh
mein gott da kommt anni mit den neuesten
drinks
[Musik]
die sehr frischen wir sind ja hier in
der red bull und das sind diese organics
wo kein red bull also keinen energie
drin ist es mit zitrone was ich hier
habe 10 von 10
mein gott ich liebe diese poppig meint
50 euro sind schon ganz schön viel aber
oh mein gott ich glaube das ist echtes
mitteilte supertoll ja klar buttons der
joy of painting ich habe gerade das
gesehen und war so plante was ist denn
plenter das ist sehr random eine fake
sukkulente in einem bob ross kopf
entscheidet euch ob ihr das gut findet
oder nicht ja und das war es dann auch
schon hier haben wir nummer fünf die
haben ja immer gesagt mindestens fünf
items ich denke mal sie meint da sind
fünf items drin oh
mein gott ist das kitschig oh mein gott
ist das kitschig das kann nicht
offiziell doch das ist offiziell bro'sis
ist happy place und jetzt guckt immer an
was hier happy place sein sondern
optimal diese zwerge an und diesen bären
dass das kann nicht das ist als ob man
einfach auf dem byblos bild gespuckt
hätte der schon alles vergeht ist nur
die frage ist es 50 euro werden wir
leben in einer inflation zeit was ist
schon geld was es wert bestimmen sie so
ein bisschen ein rein und dann geht es
weiter
[Musik]
ja hier ist jetzt einfach gerade mal so
ein motorradfahrer die treppe hoch
gefahren und am mars jetzt red bull
partner also leute freut euch findet die
wir sind schon am feiern ich bin mega
verwirrt aber ja hier auf der gamescom
passieren einfach verrückte sachen
[Musik]
so wir befinden uns jetzt hier an einem
spiel was wir ganz super interessant
finden und zwar muss man eine ruhige
kugel schieben und wir haben hier einen
ml vater markus bock ist sein name und
ja markus bock fängt jetzt einfach mal
an also wir sind jetzt hier gerade live
dabei und wie fühlt sich sagen ich habe
meine leben lang dafür trainiert ich bin
ein bisschen nervös gebe ich zu aber ich
versuche mein bestes zu geben
ambitionen er hat dafür trainiert er
gesagt sein leben lang heute
in dem weiß auch kelis holen
rang 1
wir befinden uns jetzt in der area wo es
retro spiele geben the family & friends
area und mittendrin ist kelly misses
video kreis nach heute keine fotos
orgasmus hallo also heute babbel täter
du bist die bubble in meinem team sie
redet wieder in
kleine tapioka perlen ich verstehe gar
nichts aber das ist super ja wie ein
joystick die gamescom ich bin froh dass
du hier bist weil sonst das lange
perfekt aber wir haben etwas gefunden
was wir beide ganz gut finden war und
einen bubble tea laden ja wird
allerdings als er wirkt der bald land
wirkt bis jetzt nicht überzeugend ob es
einen wirklichen guten authentischen
bubble tea dort gibt das werden wir
jetzt herausfinden komm mit ich hätte
gerne einen brown sugar milch und
tapioka kommst du da von laktose
brechdurchfall christ aber für dich mein
schatz was sagst du zu der schrift von
den betty laden klassiker
der internetgeschichte ich finde das
design ist besonders also binz aus
berlin gewohnt tolle arbeit laden
authentische damit elan zu sehen und das
ist halt ja
gamescom stand dann darf man auch nicht
vergessen würden packen die einmal im
jahr aus und dann schmeiß da holen sie
dann ihre söhne ihre kirschblüten ihren
bambus hinstellen und sagen ey leute wie
haben was hast du jetzt hier schöne uns
noch einmal zu wiederholen brown sugar
merkt ihm und tapioka perlen ohne den
berühmten klockner also diese hardcore
plastik maschine nämlich leider nicht
dabei liebe ich ja lieb ich aber dafür
und jetzt kommt der geschmackstest
ein bisschen mehr an dieser stelle sehr
lecker echt ein guter babbelt hier auf
der gamescom wasser der gekostet 88 euro
maria
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt gerade huber ja von
black pink getan zusammen tanzen kennen
konnte ja ich fand es toll
jetzt aus der endzone ja ich will jetzt
jenson jeden tag aber auf jeden fall mit
dem bubble tea im magen war das gerade
mir sehr schlecht geworden und erst
später
möchte ich nicht mehr so gut weil das
ist einfach nur das schmeckt einfach nur
mit milch mit zucker aber es sieht auch
ein bisschen eklig aus bisher einfach
nur milch mit zucker glaube aber sind
die tapioka perlen wenigstens gut oder
sind schon aber es gibt das ist so ich
freue mich wahrscheinlich ja
ok ja gut dann was gibst du den btv
punkte
von 10 10 bis 10 00 bis 2
2 von 10
du bist ein bett die experten
von 10 für den bubble tea und
wir gehen jetzt mal raus aus dieser
friends & family area wir haben zu viel
mit lego gespielt jetzt
[Musik]
leute das war's schon wieder von der
gamescom ich fühle mich wie eine
moderatorin mittlerweile zum zweiten mal
mit diesen blöden micro unterwegs ich
habe noch keine bessere lösung gefunden
deswegen mache ich einfach noch weiter
den markt also ich hab euch das video
gefallen wie sie uns das nächste mal
wieder aber das wird diesmal nicht so
viel gegessen haben aber ich hatte auch
einfach nicht so doll hunger - ja das
ist
ein kleiner schelm ist die hölle los
[Musik]